>> Okay Michael, I've drawn a little teensy
tiny graph on the screen. Can you see it?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, and some points are positive, some
points are negative. And let's just imagine, for the
sake of argument, that the green line that I've
drawn in between them is in fact the optimal
separator. It probably isn't, but let's just pretend that
I drew the right one. Now, I've just told
you that a lot of the alphas are going to be zero, and some of them are not.
So, thinking about everything that we've said, and
thinking about what it means to build, this, what
it means to build, an, an optimal decision
boundary, maximizing a margin. I want you to, t,
point to one of the posit examples that
almost certainly is not going to have a non-zero
alpha, and one of the minus examples that almost
certainly is not going to have a non-zero alpha.
That is, are not a part of the support vectors.
>> You want something that does not not have a zero?
>> Don't confuse me.
>> Do you want [LAUGH] something that's, that,
that has a zero alpha or a non-zero alpha?
>> I want something that has a zero alpha.
>> Got it.
>> That is, in some sense, doesn't matter. Okay, go.